she was a royal who hated the pressures
of royalty and aristocracy with the
comment untrue dedicated herself to
helping the poor she was also a woman
trapped in a loveless marriage whose
life was tragically cut short and I
we're not talking about Princess Diana
the beloved British royal who died in
1997 we're talking about Empress
Elisabeth of Austria better known as
Cece a legendary Beauty Cece rose up
from a bohemian background to become
co-regent of the second most powerful
empire on earth but she was also a
free-thinking woman who suffered dark
depressions and found herself stifled by
life among Vienna's 19th century elite
reviled by the rich beloved by the poor
Cece was a woman who led a complex and
tragic life even as her influence helped
shape Europe for generations to come in
a video today the tale of the 19th
century version of Princess Diana twas
the night before Christmas 1837 all
through the house not a creature was
stirring and not even a mouse best that
is you've lived in the stately home of
Duke Maximilian Joseph of Bavaria and
his wife Princess Luna Vica in which
case everything was utter chaos
the royal couple had just welcomed their
newest child into the world
young Elizabeth nicknamed Cece was one
of an incredible seven children that
Princess Ludovico had pumped out
producing a plethora of as spares the
reason for this was Princess Ludovico's
family as sister to the powerful
Austrian Archduchess Sofia her children
were conceivably one tragedy away from
becoming next in line to the imperial
throne for most kids in 19th century
household such proximity to power would
have meant a strict upbringing
luckily for baby sissy though duke
Maximilian's household it wasn't most
despite his royal position the Duke was
passionate liberal he believed in
democratic values pacifism and spending
time with a common man when he wasn't on
his estate he could be found playing
Zilla at a local tavern CeCe's charters
it was therefore a bit unusual on the
one hand she had to go to educate
lessons and things like that
like any other rich gifts on the other
those lessons were constantly
interrupted by her free-spirited dad he
would whisk the children away on
adventures this menses he grew up with
and now look deeply at odds with the
privileged world in which she lived she
certainly couldn't have known that world
was about to have to fight for its life
in February 1848 when sissy was only 10
a revolution in France snowballed into a
series of revolutions all across Europe
that threatened to sweep the old order
away in Austria Hungarian Uprising
forced Emperor Ferdinand the first to
step down CeCe's aunts the Archduchess
Sophia engineered it so her son took his
place that December 18 year old Franz
Josef became the Emperor of Austria the
second biggest power in Europe although
little cc didn't know it yet his
ascension it would change her life come
1849 the revolutions across Europe they
had been crushed in Austria Franz
Joseph's new regime it cracked down hard
on the Hungarians who'd tried to split
off from the Empire not that it was the
revolution that led sissy to catastrophe
though it was love in 1853 Franz Josef
now firmly in control of his empire
decided to find a wife his mother
Archduchess Sofia contacted her sister
Princess Luna Vica and asked if she had
a suitable daughter princess Ludovico
picked CeCe's older sister Helen that
August Helen her mother and CeCe they
all travel to bard iskele to meet
friends Joseph Cece was now 15 and
already a beauty she had flowing
chestnut hair that reached all the way
down to our ankles and eyes that people
could write sonnets about when Franz
Joseph met her all thoughts of Marian
Helen they went out of the window the 23
year old Emperor was blown away by Cece
he demanded her hand in marriage right
there and then given that Archduchess
Sofia and Princess Ludovico had come all
this way expecting a marriage they
simply cut their losses
Helen was simply shoved aside and Cece
was betrothed to the ruler of Austria it
should have been a happy time and for
Franz Josef it really was for Cece
though this was the beginning of a life
of misery
[Music]
from the moment the couple got engaged
CeCe's life it went into a tailspin
suddenly all those lessons she'd skipped
to play with dad were a big deal she had
to cram a lifetime's learning into a few
short months so that she didn't look
like a total dumb-dumb at court just as
suddenly she was being forced to sit for
portraits that friends Joseph could
parade around his empire showing off his
new wife to his subjects for the
naturally shy Cece this was as shocking
as being plunged into ice water and what
it kept getting worse that I before Cece
was due to leave for Austria a huge ball
was thrown in her honor the teenage girl
was forced to parade before a crowd of
onlookers in an expensive gown inscribed
with the Arabic for Oh Lord what a
beautiful dream but a radiant exterior
are concealed something much much darker
by now Cece had almost entirely stopped
eating it's thought that this period is
when she developed the anorexia that
would haunt her for the rest of her life
but this was the 19th century and female
suffering it was practically a spectator
sport despite of misery Cece was put in
a carriage and whisked off to the yenna
on April the 24th 1854 she and friends
Josef they were officially married
almost immediately things went so far
south they were basically in the
Atlantic life in Vinnie's Court circa
1854 was one governed by ceremony
deference and strict etiquette ignoring
any one of these things could result in
you being ostracized Cece who'd grown up
in a relaxed household she willfully
ignored all three this set Cissy on a
collision course with her new
mother-in-law from the moment her son
chucked pious Helen for this young tramp
Archduchess Sophia had been determined
to make CeCe's life hell now that the
girl was finally in Vienna so for you
decided it was time to go for Disney
villain when Cece and Franz Josef's
first child was born on March the 5th
1855 Archduchess Sophia snatched the
baby away from Cece and forbade her from
ever seeing it she even named that child
Sophia after herself
classy naturally this made Cece extra
miserable she begged her husband to put
his foot down and get the baby back the
friends Josef he was nothing if not a
mummy's boy while he wanted Cece to be
happy he also refused
to upset his mother and so when Cece
gave birth to their second child barely
a year later on July the 12 1856 there
was nothing to stop us Duchess Sophia
from snatching baby chiseler away - and
that is Archduchess so fear of Austria
folks a woman who literally stole babies
but if you thought that this despicable
behavior was it well wait until you hear
the next part
not long after Gisela was born Cece
entered her private chambers to find a
crude pamphlet lying on a desk left
anonymously the pamphlet declared that
any Empress who failed to give birth to
a boy was an abject failure to this day
we don't know who left the pamphlets but
we could probably hazard a guess
after the pamphlet introduced Cece who
we should remember is still only 18 - a
whaling wreck Archduchess Sofia wrote to
her friends you cannot imagine how
charming Cece is when she cries sadly
fate and Archduchess Sofia they weren't
done making her cry just yet if you ever
looked at Vienna on a map you'll know
that it lies close to two borders just
outside the city is the Slovak border
and its capital Bratislava known when
our story is set as Pressburg to the
south is the edge of a land far more
mysterious and alluring a land with a
long proud history that only recently
submitted to Austrian domination this
was the land known as Hungary for
Viennese society in 1857 Hungary was a
source of both fascination and revulsion
exotic revolutionary beautiful dangerous
all this may be why in the spring of
that year Cece begged her husband to
take her there on vacation perhaps
sensing how close his wife was to
cracking franz josef agreed even let her
bring the children in may the imperial
family they board as a carriage and left
at the end of a heinz for the east of
the empire from the moments they crossed
into Hungary Cece was in love it's hard
to say what exactly captured her heart
it could be the simple fact that she was
away from Vienna and her baby stealing
mother-in-law but it could also be the
language the landscape or the
informality of the Hungarian court
whatever the cause by the time they
reached Budapest Cece had given her
heart to this
downtrodden Kingdom sadly no sooner had
Hungary captured her heart than it
cruelly broke it in Budapest the family
came down with a nasty case of food
poisoning CC Franz Joseph and baby
Gisela they were recovered but baby
Sophia did not on May the 29th 1857 the
child died in CeCe's arms after two
years of barely seeing her own child
when she finally got her back death
snatched her away back in Vienna
Archduchess Sofia declared the baby's
death proved that CC was unfit to be a
mother
for her part seized he plunged into a
black depression that was painful even
by her standards she stopped eating
drinking only broth and began exercising
fanatically punishing her body for the
sins she imagines that she had committed
nonetheless the duties of life at court
continued bearly was baby Sophia cold
than Sisi who was pregnant again she
gave birth on August the 21st 1858 to
the general excitement of all
excitements because the new baby Crown
Prince Rudolf was a boy and Franz Joseph
finally had an air while Sisi may have
been suffering depression the arrival of
Rudolf did have one welcome upshot in
the way at politics of 19th century
Europe cc's inability to have a son had
rendered her powerless at court
now that she'd produced friends Joseph
an heir she suddenly wasn't quite so
weak
although Archduchess say fear still
snatched Rudolf away CC finally had some
political muscles to flex she began to
ditch boring court life spending a time
writing poetry and working out instead
she took up unladylike habits like
smoking and began to claw back her
bohemian past she also began learning
Hungarian for the elites in Vienna this
was tantamount to Sisi aligning herself
with revolutionaries as Sisi began to
excel at the language and surround
herself with more and more hungarians on
a personal staff Austrian polite society
it came to regard her as a bit of a
traitor
if the Viennese were scandalized now
well wait until sissy met count and
recei
cows and recei was the sort of guy
holocron romances are written about a
dashing Hungarian nobleman and recei had
been involved in the revolution of 1848
and seen action in the war when Franz
Josef's new regime had crushed the
Hungarians in 18-49 and recei had barely
escaped with his life
a few years later had been sentenced to
death in absentia by the end of the
1850s though and receipt had returned to
Hungary and was now living and awkward
life where basically everyone agreed not
to mention his involvement in the
revolution it was at this time that he
met CC Hogg books have been written
about the relationship between CC and
and resi exploring all of the
possibilities at the one end of the
spectrum you have histories that
asserted the two were simply friends who
bonded over their joint love of the
Hungarian language and Hungarian culture
on the other hand you have books that
suggest from the moment the two first
set eyes on each other they were rolling
in the bedsheets every time Franz
Josef's back was turned
certainly plenty of people envy and I
believed that CC was fooling around with
this handsome Count it also helps that
there were joint rumors that Franz Josef
had also taken mistresses whatever the
truth it's undeniable that CC and
Friends Joseph's relationship had
started to break down around the time
and drasi appeared in 1862 CC abandoned
Vienna began spending time abroad
Switzerland Ireland England Greece all
became sissy's ports in the storm of her
life as well of course did Hungary now
this caused even more problems than you
might be expecting in the mid 19th
century other class marriages they
weren't made for love it wasn't super
important if you spent time gallivanting
around with Hungarian men what was
important was producing heirs CC had
given her husband baby Rudolf but that
wasn't enough Franz Joseph had his heir
but
Archduchess Sofia was determined that he
also have a spare CC though she wanted
no part of this baby-making plan way
into the 1860 CC refused thousand access
to her bet at court this was an absolute
scandal it was made worse by the way
that CC was cozying up to the
insurrectionist hungarians vienna was
practically spitting her name by this
point
luckily world events were about to give
everyone in austria far more serious
things to worry about in 1862 a wily
politician became Prussia's new minister
president's known as Otto von Bismarck
he had two grand plans one was to unite
most german-speaking peoples into a
single nation and the other was to make
sure Catholic Austria absolutely wasn't
a part of his new Germany and if you
want more details on all of that we do
have a Bismarck video that you can check
out I will link to it below this one but
for now all you need to know is that in
summer of 1866 Bismarck had a plan and
he put that second part of the plan into
action the seven weeks war was as
one-sided as it sounds Prussia
steamrolled Austria the army was smashed
and Prussian troops they came close to
occupying Vienna the only reason they
didn't was because Bismarck pulled back
at the last minute preferring a
humiliated but intact Austria to a
disintegrating Empire right on his
doorstep not that the Austrian Empire
didn't try its hardest to disintegrate
anyway with Vienna humiliated the old
drive the Hungarian independence it came
roaring back as 1867 rolled into view it
seemed entirely possible Franz Josef was
going to have to fight yet another
version of the 1848 revolutionary war
but this time and something that he
hadn't had in 1848 he had Sisi
back in August 1865 CC and Franz Joseph
had taken the first tentative steps
towards reconciliation it started with a
letter CC wrote her husband saying this
she needed more control of her life more
right to see our own children by the
time of the seven weeks war CC had been
back in Vienna where she visited the
wounded and military hospitals providing
comfort to the dying come 1867 she was
close enough to both Vienna and Budapest
to prevent catastrophe the creation of
the austro-hungarian Empire from what it
once just been Austria was more than the
work of one woman but if CC hadn't been
there it could have all come crashing
down as Hungary rumbled towards
independence there were elements of the
Viennese course that wanted another war
one that would crush Budapest once and
for all equally of course there were
those in Hungary who were willing to
fight for full independence just about
the only person who could possibly talk
to both sides were CC she was able to
talk Franz Joseph out of repeating the
mistakes of 1848 and instead settle for
a diplomatic solution she was also
instrumental in getting the Hungarian
side to the table it was skilled
backroom diplomacy of the highest order
and it absolutely worked
On February the 8th 1867 the
austro-hungarian Empire it was born
without any bloodshed under the new
system the east of the empire would be
an independent state under Hungarian
control in return the Hungarians would
make friends Joseph their King and
accept joint administration of Defense
and foreign affairs for CC this meant
being crowned queen of Hungary in a
summer ceremony in Budapest count and
receive his part became Hungary's new
prime minister it was a remarkable
transformation from the carnage of 1848
and for CC her new position meant a
chance to live in her beloved Hungary in
a full time the queen of Hungary she
threw herself into charity work visiting
hospitals across the Dual Monarchy
holding hands with the dying and talking
to them not like a royal but like a
fellow human being cc's common touch it
boosted her popularity immeasurably as
did her involvement promoting new humane
treatments for the mentally ill she was
so happy that she even agreed to resume
her wifely duties on April the 22nd 1868
CC gave birth while in Budapest to her
fourth child Valerie
Valerie was the first of the Imperial
couple's children born in Hungary she
was also the first that Archduchess
Sophia didn't get her talons into CC was
allowed to raise the girl all by herself
perhaps unsurprisingly she grew to
absolutely dote on her new daughter now
ideally this would be where things kind
of ended with CC finally happy as a
mother and as an honorary Hungarian and
even as a wife but the story of CC it's
not a happy one and there are still a
lot of tragedies to come in May 1872
Archduchess sophia suffered a stroke
while in a family's Grand Palace of
Vienna as she lay dying the elite of
Austria came to pay their respects camps
ministers Royals they all passed through
her bedchamber and among their number
was CC for all Sophia seemed like a
complete villain in our story it's worth
remembering that she lived in a really
different time women in her position
were meant to be powerless Babymakers
yet sophia was able to subvert that to
take a revolution by the horns and use
it to put her teenage son on the throne
not only that she was then strong enough
to rule the court at Vienna bending it
to her will she may have been haughty
spiteful and a bit of a witch but she
was also admirable just in her own way
and maybe that's why it said that she
and CC finally managed to reconcile in
those final hours after Sofia passed
away Cece was freed of a nemesis from
now on the 34 year old and breast could
be whoever she wanted to be over the
next few years CeCe's eccentricities
both good and bad
they grew exponentially she mastered
ancient Greek became an exercise fanatic
who could have two dumbbells like a
circus strongman she also devised brand
new hair treatments that impressed the
whole empire thus happily her anorexia
continued to dominate her life as the
1870s rolled on sissy began only eating
milk based foods such as cheese
determined to keep her waist tiny yet
this could have all stayed in the
backgrounds well and not for what
happened to Rudolf by 1881 cc's only son
was no longer the baby of the family but
a melancholy lads of 22 valium he
married Princess stphanie of Belgium in
a rather ironic turn of events ICI
immediately
took against a new daughter-in-law
branding her with venom Archduchess
Sophia would have been proud of clumsy
earth just as Sisi and Franz Joseph had
done Rudolph and Stephanie's marriage it
soon hit the rocks the difference while
Sisi had managed to keep her misery
bottled up
Rudolph though he wouldn't be so strong
in late 1888 the unhappy Rudolf met 17
year old Baroness Mary and it began an
affair with her On January the 30th 1889
he took his new flame to his hunting
lodge mailing them Rudolph convinced the
poor girl that the world was now out to
get them and they needed to die for
their love Mary who was herself a
melancholy romantic she agreed taking a
pistol Rudolf shot Mary dead and then he
turned the gun on himself
when the news hit Vienna Cece suffered a
catastrophic breakdown she began to talk
about suicide telling a frightened
friends Joseph that she wanted to die
her youngest daughter Valerie would find
her laughing hysterically for no reason
finally in 1890 Cece did the only thing
she could she fled Vienna she even fed
hungry instead that broken Empress began
roaming the world travelling by boat to
far-flung shores as she traveled Cece
refused to see anyone but the crew
living a Spartan life and the bowels of
the ship when terrific storms broke out
she would order captain to tie her to a
chair on the deck so that she could be
battered by the wind and the waves
watching the sea royal and crash around
her as her soul roiled inside her breast
when someone worked up the courage to
ask what she was doing Cece simply
replied that she wanted to travel the
whole world over until I drown and I'm
forgotten and well I wish it would soon
be granted
on May the 11th 1878 a German man known
as max Hodel fired a pistol that kaiser
film the first to see past him in the
street
although the Kaiser was unhurt Hodel was
more than just a crackpot
he was an anarchist deeply committed to
something known as the propaganda of the
deed the idea that violent terrorist
actions would inspire other anarchists
to carry out more atrocities hurdles
faith would turn out to be rather well
placed his plot shot at the Kaiser was
the start of a wave of an accursed
attacks come September 1898 Sisi must
have been aware of the new threat just
four years before On June the 24th 1894
an anarchist had stabs the presidents of
France to death at a banquet two years
after that and other Anika's to gun down
the spanish prime minister but even with
these high profile killings she likely
believed that she couldn't be a target
she was at Lake Geneva with their
friends countess earnest array to seek
treatment for her ill health and not to
worry about anarchist killers this
turned out to be very fortunate for the
anarchist killer who was already waiting
in Geneva
Luigi Lucania had come to the lake after
reading the prints on Rhea Foley all
would be visiting his plan was to stab
the young roll to death but then Prince
honor cancelled his trip and the
assassin was left kicking his heels in
Geneva with nothing to do it was in this
frame of mind that Lucania found out
about Cece CeCe's visit to Lake Geneva
was supposed to be clandestine but
someone had informed the press now the
papers were full of pictures of the
Empress and with that Janie had found
his new target Cece for her part was
completely unaware of the assassin as
she and the counter strolled around the
lake they failed to notice they were
being watched until there was too late
on September the 10th 1898 the two women
were walking towards a steamship when a
passing man punched Cece in the chest
the Empress was knocked off her feet but
quickly recovered thanking those who
helped her she and the countess then
continued to the steamship as if nothing
had happened as the boat pulled away
from the shore Cece began to feel faint
the countess opened a corset for her
only to watch in horror as blood began
to seep out of an invisible wound the
passing man had been Lucini and the
punch had been a direct blow to CeCe's
heart with a sharpened file as the
countess called for help Cece fell
unconscious the steamship turned rounds
but it was too late by the time the ship
reached the shore Cece was dead when the
news reached the now captured new chaney
he said
right it put on trial he demanded to be
executed instead he was sentenced to
life in prison
twelve years later on October the 19th
1910 he hanged himself in a Cell you
Cheney's foul deed it didn't go unheeded
not two years later an anarchist chard
king umberto of Italy to death a year
after that President McKinley of America
was likewise killed one and I kissed
it's bullet thought of CC what did she
think is she lay on that steamship her
life slipping away for an answer we
could turn to her writings in the last
year's CC wrote I loved I lived I wanted
through the worlds but never reached
what I strove for it's a fittingly
tragic end to a tragic life the woman
who had everything and had nothing who
never found what her heart really wanted
but there's another ending and one
that's not quite so downbeat
not long after CeCe's assassination her
daughter Valerie wrote now it has
happened just as she always wished
quickly painlessly without medical
consultations without long anxious days
of worry for her loved ones to which
cc's friends the poet Carmen Silva added
her death was beautiful calm and great
within the sight of beloved great nature
painless and peaceful only to the world
did it seem horrific CC's life may have
been one of tragedy but it was also one
of beauty a life more intensely
passionate than perhaps any of us will
ever live at the end of baldness it's
comforting to think that maybe just
maybe they're reluctant Empress she
found peace at last so I really hope you
found that video interesting if you did
please do give us a thumbs up below and
don't forget to subscribe we've got
brand new videos just like this every
day of the week for more from me why not
check out my other channel called top
tens you will find that linked to below
and as always thank you for watching
[Music]